the upcoming game of thrones prequel
series house of the dragon is based on
georgia or martin's targaryen history
book fire and blood
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president
where in 2022 miguel sapochnick and ryan
condell will serve as showrunners and
executive producers
george rr martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood volume one
and on martin's yet unfinished fire and
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg on the conqueror
the creator of the iron throne and goes
on to recount
generations of targaryens who fought to
hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in other words it covers events from
aegon's conquest to the dance of the
dragons
that's fire and blood vol 1. the yet
unreleased fire and blood volume 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son egg on the
third train
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king and robert's rebellion that
ended targaryen dynasty
but back to aegon's conquest king argue
durandon also known as argilac the
arrogant
was the last storm king from house
duranden the rulers of the stormland
since dorian god's grief
a legendary figure of the age of heroes
and founder of storm's end
and until the conquest by aegon the
first targaryen
and before we continue i want to talk
for a moment about fantastic sponsor of
today's video
if you like game of thrones then you
will definitely love this game
from epic fights and battles to deep
character lore rage shadow legends is a
free-to-play
mmorpg game that has millions of players
and dozens of tough bosses
but its heart and soul are its amazing
champions which i like the most
the banner lords are basically medieval
knights with a massive kingdom in the
west of talaria
they're arrogant and warlike and believe
themselves to be on the side of good
but the orcs all green skinwalkers and
lizard men would disagree
the lands of the banner lords were taken
from the non-humans by force
and kept their centuries of persecution
with the help of the sacred daughter
now with the banner lords weakened by
wars of their king
the time may be at hand for these
racists to write an
ancient wrong by whatever means
necessary the fastest way to level up
your champions is through farming the
campaign
you grind xp and get loads of silver and
a few artifacts at the same time
for now here's one of my favorite
champions the skinner however the one i
played the most was the war priest
you can also fight your teammates or
fight against other players
and this month raids releasing an insane
amount of new content
first they're releasing 11 new amazing
champions
they're also releasing almost 200 brand
new missions to complete
they're also adding 5 hard new levels to
almost every single dungeon in the game
once you're in you can find me in game
under the name fire and blood
and if you're fast you can join my clan
just click the link in the description
and i'll see you in the game
house the reindeer of storm zen is a
former great house of westeros
it ruled over the stormlands until the
war of conquest
it also held much of the riverlands
until they lost them to house [ __ ]
the head of house derandon held the
title of storm king
their house's words were ours is the
theory and their sigil was a crowned
black stag
on a gold background sounds familiar
well that's because zegon targaryen's
half
brother oriss baratheon took the storm
king's seat
daughter house swords and sigil for his
own house baratheon
the title of the storm king was held by
an ancient
deranged kings who ruled the kingdom of
the storm
most of which is now the stormlands and
at one point included the riverlands
crownlands and the eastern part of the
reach
the first of the line was the reign
god's grief the mythic
first storm king and the founder of
house derandon
legend has it that he was married to
elena the daughter of the sea
god and the goddess of the wind and was
the builder of storm's end
the storm and construction was
attributed to duran
a legendary figure of the age of heroes
who earned the hatred of the sea god
and the wind goddess when he took elena
daughter of the two gods as his wife
in rage the two gods sent massive storms
to destroy the reigns keep
the rain defied the gods and built a
larger and more formidable keep
but it was also destroyed duran's
seventh keep
built allegedly with a nato brain the
builder withstood the rage of
lna's parents and gained the name of
storm's end
the storm's end became the seat of the
rulers of stormlands to storm kings for
millennia
one of the mightiest fortresses on the
entire continent storm's end has endured
many sieges
but has never fallen to any attacker in
its millennia-long history
its seabird wall is 80 feet thick with a
150 feet drop into the sea below
the castle is said to be protected by
spells woven into its walls
that prevent magic from penetrating its
defenses
the storm king during aegon's conquest
and therefore the last king of the
durandan dynasty was argilac the
arrogant
argilac was a warrior king and
considered to be old
by the time of aegon's conquest when he
was a boy
king gargilect turned back a dornish
invasion
towards the end of the century of blood
he joined the great alliance
against the tigers from volantis and led
the host
into the disputed lands marching against
an army from volantis which was
attempting to retake mir
twenty years later in the battle of
summerfield
he killed king garz the seventh gardener
of the reach
carrying the black the king of the isles
and rivers was nearing completion of his
massive castle
harrenhal and was said to be looking for
more conquests
argilac had grown afraid of herring and
so he tried to forge an allegiance we
take on targaryen
who was a dragonstone with his sisters
and their three large dragons
it is believed he wanted to create a
neutral area
serving to separate hostile forces
between his kingdom and herons
the storm king offered to aegon the hand
of his maiden daughter
argeline marriage as well as dow relins
although much of the lands were in fact
in possession of hair in the black aegon
refused and instead offered
the hand of his best friend and rumored
bastard the brother
or his baratheon argilec took this as a
grave insult
and had the hands of the enoy cut off he
sent them to aegon with a message
of these are the only hands he will
receive aegon called his banners and
took counsel with them and his sisters
as aegon had been waiting for an excuse
to use his armies and dragons on
westeros this
came in well then aegon sent ravens to
the rulers of the seven kingdoms
he informed them there would only be one
king in westeros
those who banted the knee would keep
their lands and titles
but those that didn't he would destroy
king gargilak refused to submit
aegon then strategically placed himself
between the kingdom of the isles and
rivers and the kingdom of the stormlands
so that argilac and heron could not
decide on who should take
action against him after landing and
proclaiming himself
lord of the seven kingdoms aegon named
doris baratheon the hand of the king
and sent him with a huge army and his
sister rhaenys on her dragon to take the
storm's end
although horus was met with some
setbacks he continued to march on
storm's end
king argilac refused to be trapped
inside his castle like
king herring who was roasted by
dragonfire inside his castle walls
so he came out to meet the invaders
he attacked taurus's forces while a huge
storm raged
in what became known as the last storm
which resulted with the fall of the
kingdom of the storm
and the foundation of house baratheon
argilac
outnumbered doris's army two to one as
the two armies closed on each other
a massive storm that would give a name
to the battle broke out
argue like knowing he had almost twice
as many men as the targaryens and four
times as many knights and heavy horse
decided to press the attack three
charges by arguax horsemen were slowed
by mud
although his spearmen had greater
success on foot
and the random hoes conquered two hills
during the third charge argilac broke
through
but encountered rainy set-up marxists
who destroyed their attack
by confusion arguelek was thrown from
his horse and found himself
face to face with taurus baratheon both
took a wound
but soon argilac would get his wish and
would die fighting
slain by or his baratheon his death
ended the battle
as the stormlanders yielded or fled
after her father's death
princess arjula the random barred
storm's end
and declared herself storm queen her
garrison however
feared to share the fate of karen and
revolted against
argel after a few days delivering her
door is
chained and naked nevertheless orris
treated her gently
removing the chains covering her with
his cloak
and giving her food and wine afterward
oris married darjeeling became lord
paramount of the stormlands
he took the castle land sigil and words
of house randon for his own family
house baratheon argilac got his nickname
for arrogantly refusing aegon's offer of
marrying goris a bastard
to his daughter cutting of the hands of
fake on zenvoy and sending them back to
him
he was also arrogant in engaging the
targaryens in open battle
rather than with standing a siege in the
infamously impregnable castle of storm's
end
however argilac was motivated in this by
having heard of the death of
harry and horror in similar
circumstances said hernholm
who prepared for a siege in his immense
castle only for the targaryen dragons to
fly right over the walls and burn him
inside
fargulek resisted a siege by oris
it would only be a matter of time until
the targaryens directed their dragons to
the castle
so wishing to avoid this fate argilic
met oryis in an open battle
the last storm king might have been a
bit arrogant but he was now covered but
a true warrior
his cold arrogant for refusing aegon's
proposal
and for fighting targaryens but on the
other hand
the king in the north torin stark is
called the king who kneeled because he
did not fight the targaryens
but rather kneeled to aegon prioritizing
his people
over his ego so whichever option the
storm king
had chosen he would have still had an
undesirable nickname
and he was a born warrior so death by
fighting a war was his best choice
aegon's conquest the storm king king in
the north
many epic battles all of this is part of
fire and blood
the long targaryen history and the
upcoming game of thrones prequel house
of the dragon is based on the targaryen
history
we are bound for an epic journey
starting in 2022
which is when the first episode of the
game of thrones prequel airs
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace